what about
uh conversation with Trump himself would
you do a podcast with Trump
no I I don't think so I don't think I'd
be learning anything about him it's like
with with Hitler and I'm not comparing
Trump to Hitler but Clips guy here's
your chance yeah you got this one with
certain world historical figures
um
I would just feel like okay this is an
opportunity to learn something that I'm
not going to learn I think Trump is
among the most superficial people we've
ever laid eyes on right like he is he is
in public view right and I'm sure I'm
sure there's some distance between who
he is in private and who he is in public
but it's not going to be the kind of
distance that's going to blow my mind
um and I think uh
so I think the liability so for instance
I think Joe Rogan was
very wise not to have Trump on his
podcast
I think all he would have been doing is
is he would have put himself in a
situation where he couldn't adequately
contain the damage Trump was doing and
he was just going to make Trump seem
cool to a whole new
you know a potentially new cohort of his
massive audience right
um
I mean they would have they would have
had a lot of laughs Trump's funny
I mean the
entertainment value of things is so
uh influential
I mean there was that one debate where
Trump uh you know got a massive laugh on
the you know his line you know only
Rosie O'Donnell right
the truth is we're living in a political
system where if you can get a big laugh
during a political debate you win
it doesn't matter who you are like
that's the level of of you know it
doesn't matter how uninformed you are it
doesn't matter that half the debate was
about what the hell we should do about
about uh
you know the threat of nuclear war or
anything else
um
it's
we're monkeys right and we like to laugh